tonight in the last installment of our
week-long tech tyranny series we're
going to take a look at Facebook
Facebook already knows a terrifying
amount about you probably know more than
your parents do Facebook knows where you
live where you work your favorite bands
whether or not you're happy or anxious
or depressed their algorithms can guess
when you're falling in love and do but
they want more than that
Facebook reportedly saw anonymous
medical records from several US
hospitals for unknown research purposes
but I'm sure they were fine of course
not just Facebook we'll get that
information today the company admitted
that most of its two billion users most
have had their personal information
taken by unnamed malicious actors
whatever that means but it's not good
probably Hallberg is the president of
District Media Group and she joins us
tonight Beverly how I I thought I think
most people believe that medical
information is sacrosanct is protected
by HIPAA laws I can't get my kids if I
want to how would Facebook go about
getting them they even make you sign a
document every time you go in it seems
like it's right and make sure that
everything is protected I'm not sure how
they plan to skirt around this and
that's what I think it what is so scary
about this I know that most of us expect
when we put something on Facebook our
age our zip code whatever information
you provide we expect that to be out
there but to have facebook going to
medical professionals hospitals doctors
trying to find information on you I'm
not sure how that's even allowed and the
only thing I can think of is that since
they were claiming it was anonymous you
don't have to put a name to the medical
record that somehow that was allowed but
what medical professionals need to know
is that Facebook knows how to find out
who this person is they can easily
attach any type of medical record to
what they already know about you on
Facebook
Wow maybe the answer is they paid off
Congress just throwing that out there so
this amount of personal information must
be incredibly valuable which is of
course the whole point of Facebook is to
make money for its billionaire founders
and there's nothing wrong with wanting
to sell ads that's how Facebook makes
money we wouldn't use it for free if
they didn't do that we have to move to
virtual advertising because TV isn't
quite the same as it used to in
traditional advertising but we are
talking about a company that is seeking
out information you never said they
could have so when you think even about
your phone
so you went to a hospital if you had
Facebook open on that they would know
you were there
think about GPS locators on their phone
they know how to even find out which
hospital you were at in order to connect
the data that the hospital may have
given to you to what you currently have
on your phone so this is extremely
damaging even think about what doctors
ask you they even ask you if you own
guns
think about the medical information that
doctors have that could be used to
discriminate against individuals it can
be used for blackmail
this is extremely concerning that
Facebook would even want to seek this
out because if this is also hacked what
do we do if this information is hacked
and is out there and we're talking about
Facebook which is a global entity what
happens when people's medical
information is out there I think
information is good to connect but
information like this can also destroy
people well yeah I mean it's terrifying
and it also gives enormous unprecedented
amounts of power to the company that
holds that information or you are ever
aware of any meaningful attempts to
regulate this well I think government's
gonna try to regulate it we know Mark
Zuckerberg is gonna go before Congress
on Wednesday he's going to be testifying
but I think what's concerning about this
is that I worried that there's going to
be this overcorrection and think that
government needs to regulate everything
but let's not forget there was the data
breach with OPM I don't think government
is the solution for figuring out how to
protect people's data what we're seeing
with Facebook is we have such a large
central information of data just one
hack you're talking about people's
information globally I am not sure
exactly what the answer is to protect
ourselves I think we have to do it
individually have to protect ourselves
but I think Facebook is having a wake up
call right now with Cambridge analytical
right with these medical records coming
out I think there's a big push on them
to say hey there's the data that
individuals willingly provide to use
your platform but you can't go and seek
out other and boy at least like to know
what it is I mean Hershey's can put you
know kind of whatever they want in a
candy bar as long it's not poisonous but
they have to tell you what they've
absolutely Facebook doesn't have to tell
you what they have and they should it
was great to see you thinking of early